Guten Morgen Linus.
Morgen, Andre.
Logbuch Netzpolitik mit einem weiteren kleinen Spezial. Lange nicht mehr hier als Gast, aber eigentlich äh immer noch gesehen, als äh schönes, tolles Mitglied des Lokbuchnetzpolitik Teams ist Andre Meister, mit dem,
ich heute mal ein bisschen sprechen möchte über den Zustand,
beim Staatstrianer. Wir zeichnen auf am einundzwanzigsten Mai. Ich weiß aber noch nicht genau, mit welcher Sendungsnummer diese Folge veröffentlicht wird, das seht ihr im Zweifelsfall. In eurem freien Podcast
denn auf Plattformen wie Spotify veröffentlichen wir ja aus Gründen,
nicht. Andre Meister ist den meisten von euch sicherlich bekannt als äh Redaktionsmitglied bei Netzpolitik org und aus äh als Landesverräter.
Und als regelmäßiger Gast hier in der Sendung, aber es ist relativ lange her, Andre und äh von vielen Leuten wurde mir auch gesagt, ich soll dich bei dieser Gelegenheit dafür rügen.
Ja, Corona ist schuld. Oder so.
Corona stimmt, da haben ja die meisten Leute stark am Output gelitten und konnten gar nicht mehr podcasten und auf YouTube irgendwelche Sachen veröffentlichen.
Wir hatten ja grad schon Technikprobleme in die Metaebene, wer ich auch schon mal eher wieder gegangen.
Ja, das stimmt. Äh tatsächlich. Äh wir haben ähm.
Eine lange gemeinsame Geschichte, die äh Staatstrojaner betrifft und ich glaube, dass was ich immer noch äh für eine der am wenigsten berichteten und
trotzdem auch krassesten Geschichten halte, ist dieser,
ja dann doch irgendwie ein bisschen äh gemeinsamer, aber primär auf dich und die GFF zurückgehende Erfolg.
Hausdurchsuchung bei Filmfischer.
Was war da los? Die GF hatte äh Strafanzeige erstattet. Thorsten und ich haben nach dieser Strafanzeige auch nochmal eine Bericht über den geschrieben, indem wir weitere.
Beweise zusammengefügt haben zu den schon bestehenden, irgendwie eine eine weiterführende, tiefergehende Analyse nachgereicht haben. Ähm.
Und es geht da ging bei dem Verfahren darum, dass das äh Unternehmen Gamma-Finfischer das Unternehmenskonglumrad Gamma Filmfischer in dem Verdacht steht, diese digitale Schadsoftware.
An die Türkei geliefert zu haben, wo sie gegen die Opposition eingesetzt wurde. Und dann ist erstmal eine ganze Menge nichts passiert und dann.
Äh ist das jetzt die galante Überleitung.
Galante Überleitung.
Ja, ich ich muss mal noch einen kurzen Einschub machen, also äh Ulf, Burmaier und ich, wir hatten damals die Idee für diese Strafanzeige, aber das ist eine Gemeinschaftsaktion, auch zusammen mit Reporter ohne Grenzen und dem ECCHR.
Ähm das ist tatsächlich, weil das ECCHR, das europäische Zentrum für
Grund- und Menschenrechte, glaube ich, die machen sehr viel zu Exportkontrollen, da vor allem zu Waffenexporten. Äh und Reporter ohne Grenzen hat natürlich sehr viel zu Türkei gemacht und vor allem Pressefreiheit in der Türkei.
Und zusammen mit GF und Netzpolitik das vier NGOs aber nach der Strafanzeige, die wir eingereicht haben.
Ist erstmal lange nicht viel passiert, also das Einzige, was passiert ist, ist, dass ähm.
Fischer, Mia und Netzpolitik, ORG, äh 'ne Abmahnung geschickt hat und ich glaube.
Stimmt.
Gericht äh über unseren Artikel, der leider nicht mehr in Gänze online ist. Ähm aber irgendwann letztes Jahr, lass mich nach
im Oktober genau zwanzig zwanzig gab's eine Razzia äh bei Finn Fischer wegen dieser Strafanzeige, also die Staatsanwaltschaft München, wo wir die äh die Strafanzeige eingereicht haben,
Verdacht auf illegalem Export ohne Genehmigung. Ähm die hat,
den Anfangsverdacht äh gesehen, dass sie gemeint haben, da ist was dran. Das gucken wir uns mal genauer an und haben anscheinend genug Verdacht gesehen
um äh Hausdurchsuchungen zu machen und zwar nicht nur in der Firmenzentrale in München, sondern in insgesamt fünfzehn Objekten, wie die das nennen, also Geschäftsräumen und Privatwohnungen.
Und Briefkästen.
Ja, ich die sagen leider nicht ganz genau, ähm was die konkreten, ob,
ich würde mal davon ausgehen, äh dass höchstwahrscheinlich auch die Meldeadressen der äh einer oder mehrerer Mitarbeiter von einer oder mehrere Firmen.
Ähm davon betroffen waren, also dass sie wahrscheinlich auch bei Geschäftsführern oder wem auch immer zu Hause standen, äh einer der Geschäftsführer der Fin Fisher GmbH, ist auch seit.
Ungefähr dieser Razzia nicht mehr Geschäftsführer. Äh ich habe leider noch nicht bestätigen können, ob das Korrelation oder Karussellität ist.
Ähm auf jeden Fall gab's eine Hausdurchsuchung bei fünfzehn äh Objekten und seitdem werte
die Staatsanwaltschaft in München diese Daten wohl aus und äh überlegt, ob sie den Anfangsverdacht,
ähm dass ein Export dieser höchstwahrscheinlich in München entwickelten Software, die irgendwie in der Türkei gelandet ist, wahrscheinlich äh auf illegalem Wege,
dort gelandet ist und jetzt müssen wir die Staatsanwaltschaft die redet leider nicht viel ich mein es ist ja auch.
Können sich jetzt auch nicht einfach so mit Thesen und Vermutungen äh aus dem Fenster lehnen. Ähm.
Ist auch nicht direkt der Presse sagen, was sie jetzt machen und was sie als nächstes vorhaben, äh sonst würden sie ja auch eventuelle äh Täterinnen warnen und vorwarnen
aber ich gehe davon aus, dass sie weiter diese Daten, die sie damals gesammelt haben bei der Hausdurchsuchung. Ich meine, es geht um jede Menge Akten und Computerfestplatten, halt das Übliche, was man so macht
auswerten und dann irgendwann feststellen, ob jetzt genug Beweise zusammengekommen sind, um tatsächlich.
'ne Anklage zu formulieren die würde die Staatsanwaltschaft dann einreichen und dann käme es zu 'nem Gerichtsverfahren. Wann das ist, in welchem Stadium das ist, das ist leider aus der ähm Staatsanwaltschaft nicht so wirklich rauszukriegen.
Aber äh ich fand das ja mal spannend überhaupt, dass also in so vielen Objekten
Durchsuchungen. Klar, man muss also zügelspalten. Einerseits ist jahrelang nichts passiert. Die Initiative für so einen äh so etwas überhaupt zu verfolgen, muss aus der Zivilgesellschaft kommen. Thorsten und ich haben,
auch nochmal Monate da reingesteckt, andere Leute,
noch viel mehr Zeit davor, äh um diese ganzen Beweise zusammenzutragen. Deswegen fand ich's eigentlich so ein bisschen,
ja frustrierend zu sehen, dass da gar nichts passiert. Aber als es dann passiert ist bei so vielen ähm bei so vielen Objekten eine Durchsuchung anzustrengen.
Ich sage mal, diese Durch den Durchsuchungsbefehl guckt sich selbst die Richterin noch zwei, drei Mal an, bevor sie den unterschreibt, ne? Beschluss, Beschluss.
Ja, äh da kommt ja auch noch zusammen, also,
Polizei und Staatsanwaltschaft, die haben das gemeinsam mit dem Zollkriminalamt gemacht, äh denn Verstoß gegen Außenwirtschaftsordnung und Exportrichtlinien.
Ist beim Zoll angesiedelt und der Zoll, der darf auch schon seit Ewigkeiten den Staatsröhren einsetzen. Äh da wäre jetzt die lustige Frage, ob sie vielleicht Finfischer gegen Finfischer nutzen oder so.
Wir haben ja schon vorher gesagt, wenn der Staat wissen will, ob die Samples, die da in der Türkei gelandet sind, ähm tatsächlich Fin Fischer sind, dann können sie sich ja mal ihr eigenes Exemplar, was sie ja gekauft haben, äh angucken.
Wahrscheinlich wird's nicht ganz so äh gelaufen sein, aber schon es ist schon ich wüsste nicht, dass es ähm juristisch in der EU oder auch.
Weltweit so einen unmittelbaren Erfolg,
Herstellerfirmen gab, mal abgesehen von der Klage von WhatsApp gegen NSU, die ja auch auf diversen Ebenen läuft.
Die Firmen.
Es gibt ja auch wahrscheinlich viel mehr Firmen als nur äh Hacking Team, NSO und Finn Fischer. Ähm das ist ja ein internationaler Markt, der schwer zu durchdringen ist.
Aber von denen was bekannt ist das schon ist das schon ein starkes Stück, dass der Staat da so dagegen vorgeht.
Wenn sie sich denn wirklich äh schuldig gemacht haben, Gesetze verletzt haben, was halt die These unserer Strafanzeige ist.
Ja, das äh muss also ich denke,
dass das diese Software ist und dass sie in der Türkei äh entsprechend eingesetzt wurde, steht außer Frage. Hm, der wahrscheinlichste Winkel kann ja hier eigentlich nur noch sein, dass sie,
ein Weg,
oder ein Schlupfloch gefunden haben erklären zu können, äh wie denn diese Software ähm in die Türkei gelangt ist nach diesem besagten.
Datum des Inkrafttreten in Kraft tretens der Exportkontrollen.
Wir konnten ja zumindest beweisen, dass diese Software, die da in der Türkei zum Einsatz kam
nach dem Inkrafttreten kompiliert wurde und sehr große Ähnlichkeiten zu Softwareprodukten des Hauses findest bei aus der Zeit davor und danach hat. Ähm.
Andererseits weiß man oder man weiß eben auch von Unternehmen, die unter Exportrestriktion leiden, dass die gerne mal ein paar Anwältinnen bereitstellen, um Wege zu finden, wie man das denn umgehen kann.
Internationale äh.
Nicht nur Tarnfirmen, aber internationale Firmen, Netzwerke, das sind auch komplizierte Geflechte, auch Finnfischer hat sich im Laufe der Zeit äh immer mal wieder, dass Firmen ähm,
Konstrukt dahinter äh gewechselt. Lustig fand ich, dass einer der Geschäftsführer äh im,
Zuge der Strafvermittlung per Eides stattliche Erklärung versichert hat, die fünf Fischer Lebs GmbH, die Software Finn Fischer entwickelt, ähm
überspezifisch, weiß gar nicht, warum sie das äh so on the Record noch mal ähm.
Juristisch quasi ungelogen äh bestätigt haben. Aber das geht dann gleich weiter mit die fünf Fischer GmbH, also keinen Zeitpunkt, die Software äh in die Türkei verkauft oder vertrieben.
Ist halt wirklich die Frage, die These ist, das wird in München entwickelt.
Und es ist relativ belegt, dass es in der Türkei gelandet ist. Die Frage ist, wie kommt das von Ursprung.
Ja. Da blicken wir beide auf jeden Fall sehr gespannt hin. Und wo wir beide auch sehr gespannt hinschauen, ist wie.
Ähm das rechtliche Gefüge staatstrojaner sich irgendwie insbesondere in Deutschland ähm weiterentwickelt. Wir haben darüber in Lokbuch Netzpolitik schon sehr viel gesprochen. Ich will, glaube ich,
eingangs nochmal ganz, ganz, ganz kurz erklären, worum es da geht. Ähm.
Als Staatsreaner bezeichnet man Schadsoftware, die auf den Geräten.
Der Zielperson läuft, also eine direkte Schadsoftware auf eurem Gerät oder auf dem Gerät der Verdächtigten. Ähm.
Die dort natürlich wie jede andere Schadsoftware potenziell schalten und walten kann, wie sie möchte. Es werden aber zwei unterschiedliche theoretische ähm Einsatzzwecke unterschieden, nämlich einmal.
Die ähm Telekommunikationsüberwachung, wo also gesagt wird, okay, wir infizieren dieses Gerät jetzt, weil
es es kommuniziert Ende zu Ende verschlüsselt, das heißt die Kommunikationsinhalte bekommen wir nur noch auf den Geräten der Kommunikationsteilnehmerinnen und nicht mehr, wie wir es sonst machen bei den Telefonieanbietern,
Und dann gibt es noch den Fall der Onlinedurchsuchung, wo man also quasi sagt, okay, wir machen eine Schadsoftware auf dieses Gerät und wir schauen uns alles an, was sich da so,
drauf befindet.
So die beiden theoretischen äh diese beiden theoretischen, rechtlichen Unterscheidungen in der Befugnis.
Kleine Ergänzung, du hast gesagt, äh Telekommunikationsüberwachung, Telekommunikationsüberwachung ist das klassische Handy oder Internet abhören. Sie meinen Quellentelekommunikationsüberwachung ist ihrer Wortneuschöpfung.
Und die Onlineuntersuchung, die kann natürlich alles,
alles zugreifen, was ich auf dem Gerät befindet, aber auch alles wohl zu dieses Gerät Zugriff hat. Äh also nicht nur, was auf dem Gerät selber gespeichert ist, sondern auch alle Dinge, wo man von diesem Gerät aus eingeloggt ist.
Oh, wichtiger Punkt, ja, also nicht nur das Gerät, sondern auch die äh wenn das Gerät äh zwanzig Gig hat und noch vierhundert in der Dropbox liegen, äh darf man auch dorthin.
Was sich um die Problematik dieser theoretischen Konstrukteur ein bisschen zu illustrieren.
Gibt's jetzt zum Beispiel so eine theoretische Frage. Wenn angeordnet wird ab heute wird das, wird die wird die Kommunikation von Linus Neumann abgehört. Und.
Ich habe gestern bestimmte Nachrichten erhalten, stellt sich die Frage, ne, die Schadsoftware, mit der mein Gerät potentiell infiziert wurde, die kann sowieso im Zweifelsfall an alles dran. Stellt sich jetzt also nur noch die Frage, äh liest die,
meine Inhalte nur bis zum Datum des Beschlusses aus? Oder vielleicht doch Retrograd noch ein bisschen mehr? Für die, für die Software ein,
Also eine Abitäre Beschränkung, die sie haben kann oder nicht haben kann, die aber eben auch zeigt, dass es wirklich ein theoretisches Konstrukt ist, dass es so etwas wie eine Quellen-TKÖ in dem Sinne gäbe,
wie es sich hier äh wie man es sich hier vorstellt. Also,
ähm wir beide, glaube ich, kann man ganz klar sagen, vertreten die.
Ansicht, dass die Störung der Integrität eines Gerätes äh ein absolut inakzeptabler Eingriff ist, auch im zum Zwecke.
Der Quellen-TKÖ. Da würde ich jetzt Zustimmung von dir erwarten.
Ja ist äh du du hast jetzt äh einen Punkt angesprochen ähm mit der laufenden Kommunikation oder der gespeicherten Kommunikation, wo ich nochmal drauf eingehen würde.
Ähm es gab ja schon diverse Klagen gegen Staatstrojaner und im Grundsatzurteil äh ging es BKA-Gesetz damals, hat das Bundesverfassungsgericht ja überhaupt erst das IT-Grundrecht geschaffen,
das Grundrecht auf Vertraulichkeiten, Integrität, informationstechnische Systeme.
Und in dem Urteil wurde so ein bisschen die Weiche gestellt für diese Abiturunterscheidung zwischen dem kleinen Trojaner, der nur laufende Kommunikation abhört und dem großen Trojaner, der alles äh abhört, was auf so einem Gerät ist.
Und tatsächlich heißt's in dem Bundesverfassungsgericht Entscheidungen relativ klar, diese sogenannte Quellen-Ticker Ü, die muss sich auf laufende Kommunikation beschränken,
laufender und diese Beschränkungen müssen nicht nur rechtlich, sondern auch technisch sichergestellt sein.
Nun gibt's viele große Debatten und wir haben 'ne Meinung dazu, ob das möglich ist, dass so technisch sicherzustellen.
Tatsächlich geben sich die Juristen in den Sicherheitsbehörden und die Politiker die diese Gesetze voranbringen.
Oft
große Mühe, das genauso zu definieren, zu sagen, nein, unsere Software für einen Quellen-Ticker Ü, die kann gar nichts anderes als laufende Kommunikation. Dann gab's da eine standardisierende Leistungsbeschreibung von BKA, die wir erst irgendwie frei ähm,
ja, befreien mussten und veröffentlichen mussten. Aber tatsächlich ist es nicht nur so, dass die,
die Software so entwickeln sollten, sondern die haben klare Vorgaben vom Bundesverfassungsgericht, so eine Quellenticket muss sich auf laufende Kommunikation beschränken.
Das ist schon schwer genug in der Theorie,
jeder, der irgendwie schon mal was mit Softwareentwicklung und Abhören von Kommunikation zu tun hat, fragt sich wirklich,
Wie viele Zeilen, Code, äh Unterschied ist zwischen äh gespeicherter Kommunikation äh und laufender Kommunikation äh abzufischen und auszuleiten.
Aber das ist auch noch ein rechtlicher Unterschied, denn
den Gesetzen, die seitdem gemacht wurden, äh zum erstens die krasse Ausweitung des Staates am Ende der letzten Legislaturperiode ähm auf die sogenannte Alltagskriminalität und auch jetzt in den beiden Gesetzentwürfen, die zurzeit kurz vor der Verabschiedung sind, ist immer
kurz vor Ende der Legislaturperiode macht die GroKo nochmal sowas.
Das ist genau die Chefin. Mir fällt nämlich ein, ich habe das, glaube ich, hier im Podcast auch schon gesagt. Ich fühlte mich ja inzwischen schon ungeliebt
weil ich äh mehrere Jahre nicht mehr als Sachverständiger in Ausschüssen des Deutschen Bundestags war, nämlich das letzte Mal zu genau dieser Ausweitung der des Staatstrojaners auf Alltagskriminalität. Und das ist ja ein paar Jahre her
Und es war aber.
Juni zwanzig siebzehn eine der letzten Sitzungswochenende der letzten Legislatur.
Richtig und dieses Jahr äh zwanzig einundzwanzig, exakt vier Jahre später,
innerhalb von zwei Monaten dreimal als Sachverständiger in Ausschüssen des Deutschen Bundestags, weil wir gerade wieder, ne, im Endspurt sind und
alle vier Jahre kommt dann so eine Art
Dedos der Regierung auf die Opposition, da siehst du auch schon immer die Mitarbeiterinnen und so der der MDBs, die laufen alle nur noch auf ihren Augenringen, ne? Und äh dann werden die da alle zugebombt und dann kannst du auf einmal jeden Tag dahin rennen. Und das war genau vor vier Jahren mit dieser Ausweitung
ähm des Staatstrojaners.
Hm, der so am Anfang der Legislatur muss ich ja erstmal alles setzen und man muss die großen Rahmen äh schaffen und die Stellen und sich einpendeln in den.
Ja auch.
Kontinuitätsprinzip in Deutschland, dass alles, was in einer Legislatur nicht fertig wird, dann nicht einfach ähm von diesem Stand aus übernommen wird in der nächsten äh und am Anfang wäre natürlich die großen Prestige,
gemacht, die im Koalitionsvertrag ganz oben sind und die Unstrittigen, alles andere lagert man ja erstmal eine Weile lang aus in irgendwelche Arbeitsgruppen und Gremien und Enquetekommissionen und so. Ähm,
kurz vor Schluss kommt dann das ganze Zeug auf was man sich vier Jahre lang nicht einigen konnte aber irgendwie muss man sich jetzt nochmal zusammenraffen vor allem eh vielleicht sogar die Regierung irgendwann mal wechselt und da manche Dinge gar nicht mehr möglich sind.
Aber jetzt eben haben sie sowohl in dem ähm der Strafprozessordnung für die Polizei,
als auch in den beiden Gesetzen über die wir jetzt reden nicht nur die Quellen TKÜs, sondern so 'ne Art Quellenticker Ü Plus.
Ihr Restkonstrukt ist jetzt nicht mehr nur, dass sie laufende Kommunikation abhören wollen, sondern laufende Kommunikation, Abzeitpunkt der richterlichen Anordnung,
unabhängig davon, wann sie es irgendwann mal schaffen, diese Schadsoftware dann auch auf dem Zielgerät zu installieren.
Definieren quasi das so wie früher beim äh Telefongespräch. Was man hätte abhören können, wenn man denn äh sofort den Zugriff gehabt hätte, was natürlich aber beim Staatstrainer.
Oft ungleich schwieriger.
Aufwendiger und auch nicht immer erfolgsversprechender ist. Jedenfalls ist das ein der großen Punkte sowohl in dem alten Gesetz, gegen das ja die Gesellschaft für Freiheitsrechte auch wieder Verfassungsbeschwerde eingerechnet vor vier Jahren.
Aber das dauert ja immer ein bisschen. Äh diese Urteile dann auch irgendwann kommen, als auch äh in den ähm.
Glaube auch im Bundespolizeigesetz, können wir aber gleich nochmal äh gucken, da geht's eigentlich schon mal was anderes als auch jetzt um das Gesetz für die Geheimdienste. Die bekommen eine Quellenticker Ü plus,
die dürfen zwar nur Kommunikation abhören und in der Theorie auch nur laufende Kommunikation, weil das das Bundesverfassungsgericht erlaubt hat, aber sie sagen jetzt, die laufende Kommunikation kann auch schon mal vor zwei Monaten gewesen sein.
Oder so keine Ahnung wie sich das denn verhält mit irgendwelchen weiß ich nicht verschlüsselten E-Mails, oder auch die modernen Messenger, die haben ja mittlerweile alle Frids äh also.
Teilweise kann das ja ganz schön eine Weile zurück äh reichen, diese Kommunikation.
Am Montag meiner Sachverständigenanhörung im Bundestag zur Verfassungsschutznovelle, wo das geregelt werden soll und da haben eigentlich alle Sachverständigen, die sich dazu geäußert haben, gesagt, also.
Die nicht läuft, sondern die gespeichert ist, die abzugreifen, das könnt ihr nicht einfach als Quellenticker Ü definieren, weil das ist kein Quellen TKÜ, das ist eine Onlinedurchsuchung.
Und dementsprechend müsst ihr euch auch an die Voraussetzungen.
Bundesverfassungsgericht für die Onlinedurchsuchung äh geknüpft hat, äh richten und könnte es nicht einfach äh so definieren, wie ihr das versucht, also das ist öfters mal sowas wie offensichtlich verfassungswidrig.
Gefallen, was ja so ein starker Worte von ist.
Ist es halt auch, ne? Und trotzdem muss man ja, also was man genau daran sieht, ist
es ist im Zweifelsfall schwieriger ein ein System zu bauen, was nach ab erst ab einem bestimmten Datum abgreift, als ein System zu bauen, was einfach alles abgreift, ne? Und das ist ja auch, glaube ich, so ein bisschen das, was die, was die Juristinnen halt
nicht ja, nicht verstehen, ne
dass das äh also ja, wie sich dachte, man kann in Software alles machen. Ja, ist richtig, ne? Es geht auch, aber hm, das äh von der Eingriffstiefe in das System ist es eben eine nicht unterscheidbar.
Da kommt noch dazu Eingriff äh ist ein gutes äh Stichwort, denn wie gesagt, in der ersten Staatsurteil gab's ja dieses IT-Grundrecht.
Ähm und da wird ja eben definiert, dass Grundrecht auf Vertraulichkeit und Integrität von IT-Systemen ähm und wenn man in dieses Grundrecht eingreifen will,
muss man mindestens äh als Erfahrungsjurist mittlerweile solche Dinge auch gelernt. Im Gesetz sagen, dass man daran jetzt eingreift. Aber wenn man das einfach ignoriert und gar nicht erwähnt, äh das geht halt rechtstheoretisch nicht.
Ähm wenn man in ein Grundrecht eingreifen will, dann muss man auch sagen, im Gesetz, wir greifen jetzt in dieses Grundrecht ein.
Ist ja auch in Grundrechen, die werden ja definiert in äh den ersten Grundgesetzartikeln. Der steht ja immer
Grundrechte auf Brief, Post und Fernmeldegeheimnis, Eingriffe gehen nur mit einem Bundesgesetz oder so und dann,
in dem Bundesgesetz, aber eben auch gesagt werden, wenn wir jetzt äh in Quellenticker üben würden, dann greifen wir halt in das IT-Grundrecht ein, aber in den Gesetzentwurf, die jetzt da liegen.
Wird das noch nicht mal erwähnt. Sie geben nicht zu, dass sie in das Grundrecht eingreifen, weil sie halt irgendwie aus dieser komischen Welt kommt und sie die ganze Zeit irgendjemand eingetrichtert,
haben, die Quellenticker Ü ist doch eigentlich nichts anderes als unsere normale äh Telefonüberwachung nur mit anderen Mitteln. Das das ist dort wirklich die gängige,
Praxis die Herleitung, die Rechtfertigung für alles, jede Bundestagsrede, jeder Befürworter dieser Gesetze sagt, wir können,
Kunden früher SMS und Telefongespräche mitnehmen, lesen, die sind jetzt verschlüsselt bei WhatsApp,
Also müssen wir das jetzt irgendwie magisch äh auch mitlesen. Das ist quasi eine moderne Form der äh Telefonüberwachung.
Ähm mit den technischen Details setzen sie sich nicht auseinander, definieren eben nicht, dass das ein Eingriff in das IT-Grundrecht ist und das ist halt äh da ist dann halt schon mal einer der vielen Kernprobleme aus rechtlicher Perspektive, weswegen,
dieses Gesetz halt höchstwahrscheinlich auch wieder vor Bundesverfassungsgericht angegriffen werden wird.
Jetzt muss man ja zumindest mal sagen, dass ähm.
Naiv gedacht, dieser Anspruch ja durchaus ja, sagen wir mal, formuliert werden kann, ne, dass sie sagen, okay, äh also.
Er geht mit einer Ausweitung einher, aber es ist ein eine übliche Argumentation zu sagen, hier pass auf, seid so und so viel Jahren haben wir,
dass äh äh dass das Recht,
oder das äh Strafverfolgungsmittel ähm X Y und jetzt verstößt aber auf einmal die Neuerungen der Technik, machen die Ausübung dieses Ermittlungsinstrumentes unmöglich,
für uns. Aus diesem Grunde,
muss jetzt hier was Neues eingeführt werden, damit wir diese Möglichkeiten behalten können. Ja, also ich würde sagen, gewissermaßen ist diese Argumentation bis dahin auch durchaus zu.
Zu vertreten,
ne? Ähm dumm ist, was sie im weiteren Verlauf daraus machen, nämlich dass sie dann sagen, alles klar, alles hacken und äh alles mit einreißen und äh
wirklich halt eine Eingriffstiefe da vornehmen, die in keinem Verhältnis mehr steht zur äh Telekommunikationsüberwachung.
Oder?
Ja, also ähm man kann schon verstehen, äh das ist dieses Going Dark auf diese auf die sie sich da beziehen,
Früher war alles unverschlüsselt in den herkömmlichen Telefonnetzen und am Anfang auch im Internet.
Und jetzt wird aber immer mehr verschlüsselt, vor allem Salznoten und das ist ja auch gut, dann kommen sie mit ihren Wort-Akrobatik von Sicherheit durch und Sicherheit trotz Verschlüsselung.
Ähm aus Sicht eines normalen Polizeibeamten, äh der aus einer normalen Telefonüberwachung nicht mehr so viel Inhalt bekommt, ist das auch irgendwie verständlich,
Das Problem ist nur, diese Argumentation krankt an extrem vielen verschiedenen Punkten, denn,
man vielleicht ein bisschen weniger Kommunikationsinhalt über Sprach und
nach ähm Nachrichteninhalte bekommt über eine Telefonüberwachung. Es ist ja nicht so, dass mit der fortlaufenden Digitalisierung all unserer Lebensbereiche auf einmal den Ermittlungsbehörden.
Signifikant weniger Informationen und Daten zur Verfügung stehen. Das Gegenteil ist doch der Fall. Wir hinterlassen doch noch nie so viele.
Überall wie jemals zuvor. Ähm es ist noch nie so ähm noch nie wahr, sämtliche nicht nur Kommunikation, sondern eben auch Lebensentfaltung,
Arbeit, Familie, alles, sämtliche Lebensbereiche bis hin zu irgendwann, wir reden ja von nicht,
nur abstrakt von Smartphones und WhatsApp, sondern IT-Systemen bis hin zu Autos, Smart Homes, ähm Personal Assistance bis hin zu irgendwie.
Computern, die wir am Körper haben, irgendwelche Hörgeräte, äh medizinische Geräte und so weiter und so fort,
Gibt ja noch nie so viele Daten wie vorher. Was haben wir grad wieder? Bestandsdatenabfrage. Siebzehn Millionen Abfragen pro Jahr, nur für Telefonie. Keiner weiß, wie viel das für Internetanschlüsse ist. Wir reden von Dingen wie Vorratsdatenspeicherung, von.
Die irgendwie die ganze Zeit unsere Location tracken. Das gab's doch alle vor zwanzig Jahren noch gar nicht. Ist doch nicht so, dass die Behörden.
Die ersticken doch teilweise in Daten. Nach jeder Hausdurchsuchung heißt's, äh wir haben schon wieder zwanzig Terabyte Festplatten und nachdem wir die ganze irgendwie wir Filme rausgefiltert haben, ist es immer noch zu viel Inhalt, dass wir da
Sinn machen können. Also es ist doch nicht so die mögen ein paar Dinge weniger haben. Auf der anderen Seite haben sie aber doch viel mehr.
Dann kommt noch dazu, dass äh vor allem die FDP äh hat das relativ treffend argumentiert in den äh Bundestagsdebatten.
Im Bundestag argumentiert ja niemand dafür, dass äh Polizei und Geheimdienste nicht verschlüsselte Inhalte mitlesen sollen.
Die Frage ist doch, wie und wie ist das geregelt sowohl technisch als auch rechtlich. Äh und gerade letzte Woche haben wir auch wieder ein Papier von BKA veröffentlicht.
Die können sehr wohl WhatsApp mitlesen und die können auch Telegram mitlesen das habt ihr vor ein paar Jahren schon mal besprochen indem sie einfach ein weiteres Gerät in die Kommunikation hinzufügen.
Bei diesen ganzen Messengern gibt's doch die Option, kannst du die auch in einem Desktop entweder als irgendwie Desktop klein oder im Browser oder so ein weiteres Endgerät hinzufügen.
Und das BKA kann sehr wohl einfach ein Handy in die Hand nehmen und ein weiteres Gerät hinzufügen,
und dann mitlesen das haben die internen Papier genauso gesagt und das haben wir veröffentlicht davor haben sie hier mit
Telegram sogar irgendwie auf
Telekommunikationsanbieter ebene diese Verifizierungs-SMS, die du dafür brauchst, ein neues Gerät hinzuzufügen, abgefischt. Äh und der Telekom gesagt, die bitte mal gar nicht zustellen.
Es gibt ja durchaus Möglichkeiten, Dinge mitzulesen, auch Retro gehört, wenn ich meine, wenn irgendein Richter ein Staatstrojaner absegnet.
Dann muss doch da schon so viel Fleisch Butter bei die Fische sein, äh dass dieser Richter auch eine Hausdurchsuchung absegnet, dass dieses Handy beschlagnahmt wird und da wird das an den Celebrate angeschlossen und dann wird da alles ausgelesen, was da drin ist. Das passiert doch auch täglich.
Willst du mal kurz sagen, ist dieses System, was äh die forensische,
Datensicherung von ähm Geräten macht, was wir in einer der letzten Folgen von Doktor
Netzkritik auch drüber gesprochen haben, was ein paar Sicherheitslücken hat, die unglücklicherweise ausgerechnet maximal äh analysiert hat. Oder wahrscheinlich Leute aus dem Team von Signal, nicht nur alleine. Ähm
also dem Messenger, der sich äh der jetzt ab jetzt so ein paar Dateien immer mit auf die Platte legt, die potenziell äh kaputt machen. Ähm
Ich finde einen sehr wichtigen äh Punkt, den du nennst
quasi sich in in diese Messenger-Kommunikation mit ähm einzubinden, weil das Einbringen eines weiteren Gerätes in diese Kommunikation mit der, mit der Messenger-Plattform.
Zweifelsfall bis auf dass da wahrscheinlich auch noch Retrograde Daten mit zugegriffen werden können. Äh das ist quasi so nah wie es geht an.
Einer Quellentühe. Noch interessanter wird's eigentlich, wenn du in dem Bereich gehen würdest zu sagen, aha, okay, wir möchten jetzt von.
Äh vom Linus, das WhatsApp abhören. Könnt ihr vergessen, ich benutze das nicht, aber ähm,
und jetzt würde man sagen, okay, eigentlich bräuchte man doch jetzt nur ein manipuliertes WhatsApp, was alle Daten ab Stichdatum,
noch einmal mitspeichert und ausleitet und dann hätte man tatsächlich ein dem.
Dem technischen Anspruch quellen TKÜ so nahe kommendes System wie nur irgendwie möglich ist.
Ja, weil es ist nur WhatsApp, es ist nicht E-Mail, es kommt nicht an meine Bilder ran, die äh Sicherheitssysteme auf modernen ähm Mobiltelefon.
Mobiltelefoniebetriebssystem ähm stellen sicher, dass eine App nicht in den Kontext einer anderen kommt. Klingt ja eigentlich wie die eleganteste Lösung. Dem steht aber was ganz Entscheidendes im Wege.
Das war jetzt eigentlich eine Herausforderung an dich, das zu erklären.
Grad gemerkt, es war eine Überleitung an mich. Äh ich bin äh du hast diesen Punkt aber auch im Podcast schon mal ausgeführt, oder?
Das alles schon mal im Podcast ausgeführt.
Nee, glaube ich nicht und ich ergänze das dann mit was aber in den aktuellen Gesetzesentwürfen noch darüber hinaus äh ist.
Alles klar, die die Idee an dieser Stelle wäre einfach nur zu sagen, lieber Apple oder lieber Google.
Wenn der Nutzer Linus das nächste Mal sein Update abholt für WhatsApp
dann kriegt er bitte diese minimal veränderte Version von WhatsApp, die so eine kleine Zusatzfunktion hat, nämlich äh alle Nachrichten, die getippt und empfangen werden, irgendwie noch mitzuspeichern und an uns zu schicken.
Klingt klingt elegant, hat aber leider das Problem, dass du das jetzt die Nutzerin Apple und Google nicht mehr vertrauen kann
weil die quasi im Zweifelsfall gezwungen sind, gegen deine Interessen zu agieren. Und quasi dein.
Hersteller des Betriebssystemes oder sogar des Gerätes, dem du ähm großes Vertrauen und große Geldsummen entgegenbringst, plötzlich auf
der Behörden, die Sicherheit deines Gerätes kompromittiert, also im Prinzip der Eingriff in das fundamentale Vertrauensverhältnis hier zwischen Kundinnen,
und ähm Plattformanbieterin, was auch ganz, ganz fürchterliche Konsequenzen hätte für die meisten,
unbescholtenen Bürgerinnen und für die wenigen,
die dann eben wirklich kriminell sind, eigentlich nur dafür sorgt, dass sie sagen, alles klar, aus dem App Store hole ich mir schon mal keine Updates mehr, sondern ich nutze jetzt, was weiß ich, ne, irgendwelche,
geprüften ähm raubkopierten oder sonst was. Also wir
Es ist tatsächlich ein Problem, weil bei bei jedem dieser Wege, alles, was da irgendwie versucht wird, viel mehr kaputt gemacht wird.
Als gewonnen werden kann.
Ähm wir haben jetzt noch gar nicht das Grundproblem staatstrojaner IT-Sicherheit angesprochen. Das können wir dann gleich nochmal machen. Ich gehe auf diesen Punkt ähm,
gefälschten Updates oder personalisierten Zielgruppen Updates mal ganz kurz ein. Äh wir haben ja die ganze Zeit auf allen Ebenen diese Debatte. Man erinnert sich an.
Vorstoß auf EU-Ebene vor ein paar Monaten, dieses mit Sicherheit durch und Sicherheit trotz Verschlüsselung, ähm die äh Polizei und Geheimnis.
Sagen ja die ganze Zeit die Verschlüsselung ist ganz schlimm. Wir müssen da irgendwie ran und zwar auf allen Ebenen. Äh erstens wir wollen Trojaner. Zweitens, wir wollen aber auch, ähm dass die Anbieter von,
Und helfen müssen, jetzt entweder über eine Hintertür oder vor der Tür oder Seitentür oder wie auch immer. Sie ist äh definieren
oder über Generalschlüssel, die hinterlegt werden. Die ganzen Debatten kennen mir ja eigentlich seit den ersten ähm.
Die ja aber äh ein bisschen weiter gedreht und weiterentwickelt werden. Es ist ja nicht so, dass es die Debatte und die Forderungen äh nicht gibt. Krass ist,
ähm in einen der beiden Staatsvereinegesetze, die gerade im Bundestag und kurz vor der Verabschiedung sind, ist tatsächlich eine Mitwirkungspflicht,
für Anbieter. Also zum ersten Mal hat nicht irgendwie der Staat nur das Problem wie installiert er den Staatsthroner.
Sondern der Staat schreib Anbietern und jetzt auch noch Telekommunikationsanbietern, das ist ein interessanter Parallelentwicklung, die Definition wurde nämlich auch gerade massiv ausgeweitet
Er schreibt Anbietern von Telekommunikation vor, dass die bei werden müssen. Die müssen
die Installation von Staatströdern, Zitat durch die Unterstützung bei der Umleitung von Telekommunikation ermöglichen.
Ähm also die müssen nicht mehr nur eine passive Datenkopie ausleiten, wie bei einer Telefonüberwachung, sondern aktiv verschiedene Mittelangriffe, Angriffe ausführen äh und in die Integrität,
der Datenströme eingreifen und mit der Ausweitung der Anbieterdefinition betrifft das so ziemlich jeden Anbieter,
von Internetanbieter, die ganze Palette an Diensten,
ist egal, ob das Zugang ist, also irgendwie der heimische Internet oder äh Mobilfunkanbieter oder auch Betreiber von WLANs oder Internetknoten, wie der DCX oder Back
Bohnen, irgendwelche Glasfaserbetreiber, wenn wir denn Glasfaser hätten, äh aber auch hier Anbieter, also wenn irgendwo ein Server steht bei Hetzner oder so, bis hin zu E-Mail-Anbietern, wie Posteo,
oder eben auch diese ganzen Messenger. Äh tatsächlich dieses Deutsche Gesetz will auch WhatsApp und Co
verpflichten bei der Trojaner-Installation zu helfen bis hin eben zu Appstores und Betriebssystemen,
da kommt dann eben also die komplette Bandbreite an Diensten was man so an Technologie vor sich hat und nutzt der komplette Stack.
Soll jetzt quasi gesetzlich verpflichtet werden, dem deutschen Staat bei der Installation der äh Trojaner zu helfen. Und da ist eben nicht nur das grundsätzliche Problem,
dass die Userinnen anfangen werden, den Anbietern zu misstrauen, sondern dass also das eine Problem
wäre, wenn Usern den Anbietern äh nicht mehr trauen, dann fangen die an, keine Updates mehr runterzuladen und wir schaden der ganzen IT-Landschaft, da können wir dann gleich nochmal überhaupt zu IT-Sicherheitslücken und im Verhältnis der.
Einen Sicherheit gegenüber der anderen Sicherheit. Aber unser gemeinsamer Freund hat das mal gut ausgedrückt, dass eigentlich diese Anbieter,
so eine Art Rotes Kreuz oder rote Halbmond sein sollten und jetzt nicht anfangen
können verpflichtet zu werden für den einen Staat oder den einen Geheimdienst in einem anderen Bundesland von irgendeinem anderen Staat äh jetzt anfangen, irgendwelche.
Ähm was auch immer, Betriebssystem-Updates,
psst äh Versionen oder Internetpakete oder WLAN-Pakete oder was auch immer, auszuliefern,
dann haben wir nicht nur ein Problem, dass wir die IT-Sicherheit insgesamt schwächen, sondern äh das ist irgendwie äh so funktioniert,
das Netz nicht, dann machen wir doch komplett ähm den kompletten Steck kaputt äh im bei der Anhörung hat er,
Sachverständiger am Montag gesagt, das würde das komplette Vertrauen in die IT-Sicherheit an sich erschüttern und wenn wir doch an einem nicht.
Haben, dann ist es IT-Sicherheit, jeder,
sich alle naselang über irgendeinen Angriff oder irgendeine andere falsch angeklickte Echse oder makro oder so was auf. Der Russe kommt und heckt unsere Wahl,
ist ja nicht so, dass wir zu viel hätten, die wir aufs Spiel setzen können, nee, die IT-Sicherheit ist ohnehin schon überall kaputt.
Anfangen grundsätzliche Prämissen dieser ganzen Welt noch weiter kaputt zu machen.
Und ich finde wirklich diesen Vergleich von Chris halt wirklich entscheidend. Also stell dir also wenn du den,
den ähm dem Roten Kreuz, dem Roten Halbmond nicht mehr vertrauen kannst in einer äh in einer,
kämpferischen Auseinandersetzung, ne? Wer sind diejenigen, die darunter leiden? Die Verletzten, ne, die äh die die Zivilgesellschaft, die mit dem ganzen Scheiß Krieg eigentlich nichts zu tun haben will,
kann jetzt am Ende noch nicht mal mehr trauen, dass wenn der Krankenwagen kommt, dass der nicht auf einmal äh eine Maschinenpistole.
Geiseln nimmt, ne? Das ist der eine Punkt, der zweite ist, ähm.
Diese Internationalität, all das, was was hier in Deutschland irgendwelche ähm grauhaarigen,
Leute fordern ja? Wenn das Gleiche werfen sie China vor, da werden sie nicht müde.
Zu sagen, ja China, ganz fürchterlich hier, ne? Dürfen wir jetzt mal aufpassen, der Chinese? Von dem dürfen wir kein kaufen.
Weil der bestimmt dem können wir nicht vertrauen, so so ein schlimmer Finger ist das, ne? Aber quasi genau das, genau das, was sie, was sie denen ähm vorwerfen
Ist ja das, was sie selber äh beanspruchen und beanspruchen zu tun. Das hatte ich übrigens auch äh kleiner äh self plug hier in der äh
Auskunft zum IT-Sicherheitsgesetz zwei Punkt null, mal ausgeführt, um einfach mal zu sagen, aha, okay.
Nehmen wir doch mal wirklich eure gesamte angebliche Huawei-Problematik hier auseinander und
zeigen euch mal das Huawei eigentlich nur das kleinste Problem wäre vor dem Hintergrund, was ihr selber ja quasi die ganzen Funktionen, die ihr verlangt oder die ihr fürchtet.
Die sollen an anderer Hand äh an an anderer Stelle aufgrund eures Verlangens überhaupt eingebaut werden,
also das ist äh wirklich sehr ähm sehr widersprüchlich, diese diese Argumentation.
Nationale Perspektive äh auf irgendwie der globale Kommunikationstechnologie ist wirklich oft sehr, sehr beschämend.
Vielleicht kann ich jetzt kurz einen Einschub machen, weil wir so ewig nicht ein Podcast geredet haben hier zu emoted. Da war ja auch das Ding.
Schadsoftware vom BKA, das BKA hat mal eben Software auf dreiundfünfzigtausend Rechnern in der ganzen Welt installiert, um äh zu deinstallieren.
Jetzt mag man sagen, äh der Deutsche Reststaat und das BKA, die sind vielleicht noch ganz lieb und die meinen es noch net, übrigens ein paar Wochen
mit dem Exchange hat das FBI genau das nicht in der ganzen Welt gemacht, sondern nur auf Rechnern,
in den USA. Aber jetzt stellen wir uns doch mal vor, was an was passieren würde, wenn irgendwie Südafrika oder Brasilien oder Bangladesh oder wer auch immer anfangen würde,
dreiundfünfzigtausend ähm Rechner, Windowsrechner in der ganzen Welt, inklusive in Deutschland zu updaten. Ähm.
Skandal, jetzt können wir uns nicht gefallen lassen, da müssen wir deutsche Bürgerinnen vor schützen.
Eben äh und ähnlich ist es eben mit so einem Zugriffs äh Rechten, wenn man irgendwie jetzt den Facebook in Deutschland verpflichtet.
Gepatchte WhatsApp-Version an irgendeine Zielperson auszuliefern
hindert Russland und Türkei oder wen auch immer Marokko äh daran, genau das selber zu fordern. Das war ja genau das Problem hier mit Apple versus FBI.
Dass eben Technologie so gebaut wird, dass jeder unbefugte draußen gehalten wird.
Oder nur äh oder nur die ganz Dummen. Also das ist halt das Problem von Technologie. Entweder sie ist richtig sicher oder richtig kaputt,
und dann kann man halt auch keine Ausnahme machen und sagen, nee, die hundert anderen hundertneunzig Staaten, die sollen dadrauf nicht zugreifen können, aber das Bundeskriminalamt,
so funktioniert das halt international nicht.
Das ist äh wirklich das ist sehr schön zum zum Ausdruck gebracht. Jetzt müssen wir langsam, jetzt haben wir, glaube ich, nochmal und ich finde das auch gut, dass wir jetzt mal wirklich im Schnelldurchlauf,
fünf fünfundvierzig Minuten ungefähr, äh vierzig, fünfundvierzig Minuten. Die Problematik, Staatstrojaner geschildert haben. Und jetzt,
und damit eben den Eingriff in die Integrität von Systemen, ja, dass davon hier niemals vergessen. Und das ist der Schwerwiegendste Eingriff. Ähm der äh im Bereich der IT-Sicherheit,
möglich ist in der man könnte noch in die Vertraulichkeit bei der Übertragung eingreifen, kann in die Verfügbarkeit eingreifen aber in der wenn man bei der Integrität ist dann heißt es immer man kann schalten und walten wie man möchte. Und hier wird,
unter dem ähm unter der Schilderung des Bedarfs einer Vertraulichkeitsverletzung eben die Integritätsverletzung,
vorangetrieben. Die letzte Änderung, gesetzlich haben wir gerade schon gesagt, zwanzig siebzehn, die Ausweitung dieser Befugnis auf.
Alltagskriminalität. Ähm.
Auch das ein üblicher Vorgang, ne, eine Befugnis wird irgendwie für für schwerste, für schwerste äh Bedrohung von Leib und Leben äh im im Ausnahmefall.
Anfang waren nur das BKA nur zur Prävention, zur Verhinderung und nur von internationalen Terroranschlägen.
Das war, das war die Beschränkung ganz am Anfang zwotausendneun. Und dann schwupps eine GroKo später.
Acht Jahre später.
Ähm für den kompletten Katalog an schweren Straftaten irgendwie über vierzig, ich glaub bis an die fünfzig oder so und in der Praxis wie zu erwarten vor allen Dingen Drogen und Eigentumsdelikten oder so eingewendet.
Und jetzt geht's in den dachte man eigentlich schon fast so ja vielleicht haben sie es ja jetzt auch einfach durch, aber jetzt gibt es zwei weitere Gesetzesvorhaben, die noch vor Ende der Legislaturperiode,
werden sollen. Und das ist ähm einmal.
Die äh das Gesetz zur äh zur Erleichterung der Arbeit der Geheimdienste, ne, so ungefähr heißt das.
Ja, äh so heißen
gute Geheimdienstegesetz. Äh nee, das ist tatsächlich äh die Verfassungsschutzrechtnovelle. Das ist mal wieder so ein Artikelgesetz, was irgendwie sieb
äh zehn Gesetze auf einmal anfasst, also das Verfassungsschutz äh Bundesverfassungsschutzgesetz, das Artikel zehn Gesetz in den Grundrechtseingriffe, äh Sicherheitsüberprüfungsgesetz und so ein paar andere,
ähm,
Genau, aber es wird gemeinhin als die Verfassungsschutz-Novelle bezeichnet, was ein bisschen irreführend ist, weil das äh dann im Endeffekt für alle Geheimdienste gibt und wir haben in Deutschland übrigens neunzehn,
auf Bundesebene äh BND MAD und Bundesamt für Verfassungsschutz. Das gilt aber dann eben auch für alle sechzehn Landesämter für Verfassungsschutz.
Muss man vielleicht nochmal kurz äh erklären. Also die also es wird nicht es kommt nicht also wenn bei solchen Gesetzesänderungen
kommen nicht immer nur neue Gesetze, ne? Da wird jetzt nicht ein neues Buch gedruckt, steht drauf, ähm Verfassungsrecht, sondern viele Gesetze sind im Prinzip der deutsche Bundestag hat
beschlossen, in Paragraph Y äh in Paragraph drei des Gesetzes XY in seiner Fassung vom so und zur vierten Sohn,
wird folgender äh Buchstabe Z hinzugefügt. Z äh.
Bei Gefahr für Leib und Leben. So und das ist tatsächlich der Gesetzestext und da muss man sich muss man sich quasi die alte Fassung holen.
Muss gucken, in welchem Kontext wird da jetzt überhaupt etwas geändert? Und dann kann man irgendwie die ne die juristische und gesellschaftliche Bedeutung ähm
erfassen. In der Regel sind diese Gesetze begleitet durch eine ganze Reihe an äh Erläuterungen, wo also gesagt wird, was soll damit gerade passieren, aber als jemand, der jetzt schon mehrere Male solche Gesetze auch als Sachverständiger,
vor äh im Deutschen Bundestag beurteilen musste und,
Andre, der diese Dinger immer alle lesen muss, weil er sie schon vorher als Journalist aufarbeiten muss. Das ist nicht immer sehr einfach. Und die Änderungen sind potentiell von von sehr hoher Tragweite und man kann da wunderschön Sachen drin verstecken, ne.
Nicht nur die Änderungen, also die Gesetze, die beschlossen werden
ähm sind nicht immer sehr einfach, wie du das jetzt ausgedrückt hast mit diesen Änderungen in Paragraph X und Y, sondern selbst die fertigen Gesetze,
die ihr dann eigentlich nicht mehr nur in Diff sind, äh sondern das, was auf Gesetze im Internet DE und im Bundesgesetzblatt steht.
B sind extrem kompliziert und verschachtelt. Erst am Montag bei der Anhörung äh haben irgendwie Jura-Professoren, also die,
mehrere und Matthias Becker, der schon mehrere Verfassungsbeschwerden gewonnen hat. Selbst der hat gesagt, die Geheimdienst Gesetzgebung in Deutschland ist in einem beklagenswerten Zustand. Die Gesetze sind nicht lesbar, in sich zersplittert,
eigentlich selbst von ausgebildeten Juristen kaum äh Verstehbar, kaum bewältigbar, weil das eben alles so.
Da gibt's die Telekommunikationsüberwachungsverordnung und das Artikel zehn Gesetz äh und,
einzelnen Geheimdienste verweisen dann jeweils in Befugnisse auf das andere, über die Jahre hinweg, wurde dann aber etwas Neues da eingefügt, was mit dem ursprünglichen gar nichts mehr zu tun hat. Also selbst Juristen.
Verstehen diese ganzen Kreuzfahrweise nicht nur in den Änderungen, sondern auch in den fertigen Gesetzen gar nicht mehr so einfach und der endgültige Polizist oder Geheimdienstmitarbeiter, der dann so eine Maßnahmen anordnet,
übrigens auch nicht. Auch in äh verschiedenen Anhörungen in den letzten Wochen und Monaten,
Bundestag haben die alle gesagt, ja also die müssen dann selber von ihren Juraabteilungen äh so arbeiten lassen, was das denn jetzt eigentlich bedeutet.
Ähm vielleicht also wie kommt es zu diesen Verwirrungen, ne, die Texte sind komplex und die haben verweise aufeinander. Ja, da ist du weißt zum Beispiel nicht, wenn irgendwo,
in dem einen Absatz steht schwere Straftat ist, ja, dann steht halt in fünfundzwanzig anderen Gesetzen was weiß ich, das darf die Polizei bei schweren Straftaten,
ne? Und diese diese das wäre jetzt ein einfaches Beispiel für, wenn du,
wenn man jetzt ins Gesetz schreibt, äh das und das ist jetzt auch eine schwere Straftat, dann denkt man, das ist eine kleine Änderung, die.
Bedeutung für was das bedeutet, für unterschiedliche Polizeibehörden und so weiter, ist aber eben von besonderer,
weiter. Und das ist jetzt nur mal um eine Ecke gedacht und wenn jetzt äh Juraprofessorinnen und Juraprofessoren sagen, hier das das versteht ihr sowieso gar keiner mehr,
dann heißt das letztendlich, dass wir ähm ja im, im, dass wir unsere eigenen Rechte und äh unsere eigene Gesetze halt so kompliziert gemacht haben und so unklar, dass in der Realität so viele Graubereiche entstehen, dass.
Ne, dass dass du dann eben, ja, was hast du dann? Dann kommt irgendwann AdWord Snowden,
und da musste so und so viele Jahre Untersuchungsausschuss machen und dann werden die Fehler an den Gesetzen gefixt, weil wir wissen ja, das Gesetz hat ja gegen die Geheimdienste verstoßen.
Und das ist jetzt irgendwie nur historisch gewachsener Ballast der Bundesrepublik. In wie viel haben wir jetzt? Zweiundsiebzig Jahre. Äh wenn Pi mal Daumen.
Ähm ganz so schlimm wie UK wurde irgendwie dann nur historisch gewachsenes Recht aus einem äh aus einer.
Aus einer so rechts, die haben ja so ein ganz anderes Rechts
Theorie, mir fällt es der passende Begriff nicht ein, aber da ist es ja möglich, dass sie dann irgendjemand in irgendeinem Prozess mal noch einen Erlass vom dreizehnten Jahrhundert äh hervorzieht, der dann irgendwie jetzt noch argumentier und anwendbar ist. Also ganz so schlimm ist es hier nicht
aber trotzdem,
Ähm es ist tatsächlich oft über mehrere, nicht nur eins, zwei, drei Hobs und Ecken äh gedacht. Äh und selbst wenn man die Möglichkeit hat, alle Gesetze zu lesen, zu verstehen
und sich dran zu erinnern, ist es nicht einfacher sich auszumalen, was das jetzt tatsächlich in der Gänze bedeutet.
Zum Beispiel ähm gab's ja den Streit zwischen SPD und Union, ähm dass der Staatstrojaner jetzt an die Geheimdienste, nicht an alle Geheimnisse gehen sollte,
sondern angeblich nur an das Bundesamt für Verfassungsschutz und auch nur bei Hinweisen äh von ausländischen Geheimdiensten auf schwere Staatsgefährdende Straftaten.
Aber dann haben sie diese Befugnis eben ins Artikel zehn Gesetz geschrieben, Artikel zehn, Grundgesetz ist,
Post im Fernmeldegeheimnis, Artikel zehn Gesetz ist das Gesetz, was in das Briefpost und Fernmeldegeheimnis eingreift,
Und wenn man in darin eingreift und irgendjemand die Befugnis ähm
drin regelt, aber dann in den ganzen Geheimdienst, eigenen Gesetzen von Bund und Ländern steht, die dürfen das, was im Artikel zehn Gesetz steht, ähm dann dürfen das halt auch gleich alle. Und das ist jetzt nur ein relativ einfaches äh Ba,
Bier, was aber schon verdeutlicht, in welche Richtung das da auch noch kompliziert.
So, jetzt haben wir also die Idee, ein wir möchten, dass äh des Verfassungsschutzrecht anpassen. Man denkt also, es geht nur um den Verfassungsschutz, geht aber um noch viel mehr.
Genau, äh du in der Verfassungsschutz-Novelle soll im Artikel zehn Gesetz eben die Möglichkeit für die kleinen Trojanerquellen TKÜ.
Im Artikel zehn Gesetz geregelt werden und das gilt halt sowohl für den Bundesamt für Verfassungsschutz, das ist auch der, der immer in den Debatten genannt wird, der das kriegen soll, aber eben auch für den BND.
Der ja bis vor einem, wann war das? Ein halben Jahr oder einem Jahr ist das BND-Gesetz verabschiedet wurde.
Explizit die Befugnis hatte zu hacken, sondern die haben das immer nur implizit gemacht mit ja wir unsere gesetzliche Auftrag ist Informationen zu heben, also dürfen wir ja wohl auch hacken,
jetzt ist zum ersten Mal geregelt, dass sie hacken dürfen, aber die können auch gleich ganze Netze hecken, wurde damals ja genug.
Der andere Bundesgeheimnis ist der MAD, der soll das jetzt auch dürfen, aber eben auch alle sechzehn Landesämter für Verfassungsschutz, also bis hin zu,
Verfassungsschutz Saarland, Verfassungsschutz, Bremen und den äh vor zehn Jahren besonders bekannt gewordenen Verfassungsschutz Thüringen.
Die sollen jetzt Geräte hacken dürfen von Leuten, die sie beobachten und bei den Geheimdiensten geht's ja darum, Leute beobachten,
keine Straftäter sind, äh weil sonst wär's ja die Polizei, die die äh Überwachen und dann irgendwann auch mal vor Gericht stellen würde, äh sondern die verfolgen halt alle, die so im Geheimdienst äh im Verfassungsschutzbericht stehen,
fallen dann halt auch schon mal irgendwie Klimaaktivistinnen oder äh Verfolgte des Nazi-Regimes drunter.
Den Staatstrojaner bekommen, wobei.
Die Herleitung ist dann immer, dann wird viel gesprochen von äh Hanau und Halle äh und Walter Lübcke und so.
Aber wenn man mal zurückdenkt bis zum NSU, das Problem war ja nie, dass die Geheimdienste nie genug konnten,
Es war ja nicht so äh dass die Datenerhebung irgendwie das Problem gewesen wäre. Das Problem ist doch einfach, dass sie nicht, dass sie auf dem rechten Auge blind waren und nicht genau hingeguckt.
Das Problem von einem Verfassungsschutz unter Maaßen war doch nicht, dass die kein Trojaner hatten, sondern dass sie die fucking NSU-Akten geschreddert haben.
Also da gibt's ja auch äh jede Menge Erfolgsgeschichten, Oldschool Society und so so eine sächsische ähm,
Neonazi gegen die vor Gericht,
Stand, wahrscheinlich so verurteilt wurde, äh wenn man Polizeiarbeit ordentlich macht in den Gerichtsakten steht dann halt auch,
Telegram-Chats ist ja nicht so, dass man das dann mit ordentlicher Polizeiarbeit, wenn man die aufm Kicker hat, beobachten will und aus dem Verkehr ziehen will, wenn sie vielleicht sogar schon Straftaten begangen haben, dass es dann keine Möglichkeiten,
aber das ja die Herleitung ist halt.
Hanau, Halle, Lübcke, der Verfassungsschutz muss jetzt irgendwie uns vor diesen Anschlägen auch mit dem Trojaner schützen.
Auch wenn das bei diesen Beispielen überhaupt nicht geholfen hätte.
Ja die die angebrachten Beispiele, das das war noch ein letzter Punkt, den ich zu diesem Going Dark halt sehr interessant finde. Er wird ja auch ein ein klassischer Fehlschluss gemacht, indem man sagt, die alles, was wir nicht aufklären konnten.
Und keine hatten wo ja einfach die postuliert wird,
gebt uns diese Werkzeuge und dann ist gut. Ne? Und wenn man dann aber schaut, was haben die was haben die gebracht in den Ländern, wo sie zum Einsatz kommen, stellt man auch wieder fest, ja nix, ne, hat man man kriegt die Leute mit klassischer und ordentlicher Polizeiarbeit. Ähm
sodass hier ja diese Going Dark-Debatte wirklich der es ist halt einfach nicht.
Äh sauber argumentiert leider, ne, oder zum.
Ja doch oft wirklich nur eine Frage von.
Wie guckt man hin? Dann war jetzt glaube ich in der sachverständigen Anhörung auch noch das Beispiel
Die äh Querdenker da, die die Reichstagstreppe gestürmt haben, da hilft doch kein Staatstrüger, ne? Die haben das doch öffentlich auf Facebook angekündigt.
Klar nahmen. Das Problem war doch nicht, dass die Informationen nicht da waren, sondern dass sie nicht ernst genommen wurden. Genauso wie jetzt am sechsten Januar vorm Capitol in Washington. Da haben doch davor schon Leute gewarnt.
Könnte sich irgendwie äh jetzt.
T-Shirts an, wo draufstand äh.
Genau äh und da da ist das Problem doch nicht, dass man nicht.
Befugnisse hat, zumal wir doch auch schon seit vielen Jahren äh berichten, was die äh die Polizei und die Geheimdienste im Internet dürfen, zu Landesverrat, ein ähm zu dem Artikel damals, da ging's ja auch darum,
was wir veröffentlicht hatten über die Fähigkeiten des Bundesamts für Verfassungsschutz um eben soziale Medien auszuwerten und zu beobachten und wenn sie das einfach mal gemacht,
vor dem Rechtstagstreppenstürmung, dann hätten sie auch vorher von Jana aus Kassel und äh wie heißt der hier? Ja.
Jetzt abgehauen ist, na diese ganzen Lumis. Äh die hätten ja genau, ja.
Der ist ja von den der ist ja von den Schergen des Merkel Regimes in die Türkei geflohen. Oh man.
Und dann, also hier, Geheimdienste, ne? Die wollen angeblich ähm ich weiß auch nicht so ganz genau, was sie machen. Sie beschreiben sich als Frühwarnsystem,
gab's vor kurzem hier diesen öffentlich rechtlichen Film Verfassungsschutz, ist es ein Frühwarnsystem wo ich mich echt frage, was machen die denn die ganze Zeit? Jetzt hatten die Verfassungsschutz in Sachsen äh Pegida,
als potentiell rechtsextrem eingestuft. Was ist denn da das Frühwarnsystem? Das sagen die Leute seit Anfang an. Das Problem ist doch dann, da nicht hinzugucken
aber die Geheimdienste tun dann so, als ob sie den ganzen Tag Terroranschläge verhindern, wobei das Verhindern von Terroranschlägen, das ist gar nicht Aufgabe der Geheimdienste, das ist Aufgabe der Polizei. Das BKA darf seit zwotausendneun Staatsröhren einzusetzen, um Terroranschläge zu verhindern.
Das ist doch genau das, warum das damals ganz eng begrenzt ähm eingeführt wurde.
Es kann doch jetzt schon absehen, dass wenn die das ähm das Mittel einmal haben, dass dann eben nicht nur,
der nächste NSU, sondern eben auch die Ende Geländegruppe XY davon betroffen ist.
So viel zu den Geheimdiensten. Das andere Gesetz, was ja gerade in der Pipeline ist, ist das Bundespolizeigesetz,
auch alle Polizeien dürfen ja Staatsverhältner einsetzen, seit der letzten Neuregelung in der Strafprozessordnung. Aber jetzt soll die Bundespolizei den Staatsmann erkriegen
Personen, die gegen die noch gar keinen Tatverdacht begründet ist. Das war jetzt ein Zitat aus der Gesetzesbegründung, also schon präventiv schon irgendetwas passiert ist. Gegen Leute, die noch gar keine Straftat begangen haben
Saskia Essen und die SPD auf keinen Fall mitmachen, auf keinen Fall präventiv,
aber ich würd ehrlich gesagt nicht darauf wetten, also erst heißt es nur Verhinderung, Terror, dann nur zur Verfolgung schwerster Straftaten und jetzt ist es vor Straftaten und für die Geheimdienste. Das ist doch die klassische Salami Taktik auf,
auf der ganzen Ebene.
Also das wird den hat noch gar keine Straftaten begangen. Das müssen wir jetzt nochmal genauer erklären. Ähm ich habe mir mal vor einiger Zeit von Lea Beckmann äh erklären lassen, die Aufgaben der Polizei sind,
Strafverfolgung und Gefahrenabwehr, ne?
Äh also in der Rechtstheorie bin ich da jetzt nicht ganz sicher, ob Prävention und Abwehr ähm ähnlich sind, aber die sollen teilweise auch Straftaten verhindern.
Ja, kann sein, dass Prävention, Untergefahren, Abwehr subsummiert ist, aber ich bin tatsächlich genauso wenig Jurist wie du.
Genau, wir sind beide keine Juristinnen und deswegen äh verweisen wir auf diese Folge Lokbuchfreiheit. Da ist das drin erklärt und da hat die äh Lea mir das super erklärt. Ich mache mir kurz eine Notiz, dass das in die Shownotes kommt. Ähm.
Und äh jetzt haben wir auf jeden Fall diese diese, also worum wir uns so, glaube ich, einig sind, ist das der Staatstrojaner hauptsächlich im Rahmen der Strafverfolgung zum Einsatz kommen.
Ja, das ist derzeit
ähm die einzige Form wir äh also neben dem äh Verhinderung, also der Prävention von internationalen Terror, das ist BKA seit zwotausendneun durfte. Aber was höchstwahrscheinlich noch nie angewendet hat, weiß sowohl technisch als auch rechtlich heiß ist. Äh die Fälle, die wir in den letzten Jahren haben, waren zur Strafverfolgung von Drogendelikten
und so. Also wie eine klassische Telefonüberwachung auch.
Und Strafverfolgung heißt, es hat auf jeden Fall schon mal eine Straftat stattgefunden.
Äh es es besteht genug Verdacht, dass die Polizei und Staatsanwälte einen Richter überzeugen können, dass eine Straftat stattgefunden hat. Das heißt ja nicht, dass es in jedem Fall auch zur Anklage kommt und dass es nach einer Anklage auch zur Verurteilung kommt.
Aber es hat zum, es besteht genug Anfangsverdacht, dass eine Straftat äh stattgefunden hat.
Also es es wurde ein eine eine äh illegalisierte Substanz wurde gehandelt äh äh gehen wir von aus, irgendjemand hat sie und wir ne, nehmen wir das Beispiel aus dem Leben, wir gehen davon aus, X Y hat das
getan. Ja, aber ist ein eine Händlerin dieser verbotenen Substanz. So und.
Jetzt aber quasi zu, du, wenn du noch nicht einmal mehr das brauchst, was brauchst du denn dann?
Geil, ne? Aber ich habe hier den Gesetzentwurf, den die GroKo beschließen würde vor mir und ich kann gerne aus der Gesetzbegründung zitieren.
Präventive Telekommunikationsüberwachung solcher Kenntnislücke der Bundespolizei schließen und sich gegen Personen richten.
Die noch keinen Tatverdacht begründet ist und daher noch keine strafprozessualen Maßnahmen nach Paragraph hundert A Strafprozessordnung angeordnet werden kann.
Diese hundert A SDPO ist die normale Telekommunikationsüberwachung und eben auch die Quellenticket Kommunikationsüberwachung zur Verfolgung von Straftaten und die meinen,
Ja, das dürfen wir zwar, um Strafverfolgung zu machen
Wir wollen das jetzt auch, dürfen, wenn wir das da noch gar nicht dürfen. Äh wir wollen das jetzt machen können, wenn wir das nicht dürfen um eine Straftat zu verfolgen, sondern gegen Personen, gegen die noch kein Tatverdacht begründet ist.
Um eben, weiß ich nicht, Straftaten abzuwehren, zu verhindern im Vorfeld schon.
Das ist schon eine also das ist irgendwie.
Die argumentieren ähm äh vor allem die Bundespolizei mit Schleuserkriminalität und so. Da kommt dann in der Debatte auch äh immer gleich das,
piel mit den ähm Schleusen, Leuten in irgendeinem LKW, die dann da drinnen erstickt sind oder so, ist ja immer die ganz grauenhaft
Fälle, die man äh sich wünschen würde, die tatsächlich gar nicht erst passieren. Aber wenn aber trotzdem, wenn man einen Richter davon überzeugen kann,
so eine Maßnahme anzuordnen, gerade in den äh Staatstrojanern, also eine extrem invasiven Maßnahmen, dann muss man doch schon genug Verdacht haben, dass die Leute einen konkreten Straftat ähm,
verdächtig sind. Und das ist hier halt nicht der Fall. Und wie immer.
Natürlich soll es erst nur die Bundespolizei und das nur gegen ganz böse Schleusungskriminalität kriegen, wobei Schleusungskriminalität äh könnte man auch innerlich diskutieren, weil das wird ja auch Sea-Watch und Co vorgeworfen. Ähm.
Aber wenn das einmal da ist, wird das natürlich auf die anderen Polizeibehörden und auch auf andere Straftaten äh Deliktsbereiche ausgeweitet werden. Das ist doch ganz klar, ist doch immer so.
Klar, die haben da ja eine Lücke.
Also dieser Begriff Lücke ist sowieso sehr äh äh sehr, sehr schön, ja? Sehr, sehr elegant gewählt. Ähm die die Lücke nennt man äh Grundrechte in der Regel, ne?
Ja, ich meine, die Polizei in einem Rechtsstaat darf nicht alles. Ja, äh das Grundrechte sind Abwehrrechte auch gegen den Staat.
Die Lücke nennt sich Rechtsstaat.
Es gibt selbst in nicht Rechtsstaaten.
Äh selbst in Diktaturen, mit umfassender Überwachung und keinerlei Bürgerrechten und ähm absoluter Vollüberwachung und Befugnisse selbst dort passieren Straftaten. Äh also es ist.
Tatsächlich eine konzeptfrage, eine Aushandlung, wie viel es notwendig, wie viel ist sinnvoll? Ähm und genau diese Einschränkungen äh von angemessen und notwendig. Äh die muss halt immer wieder neu verhandelt werden.
Und
man könnte hier argumentieren, dass es weder angemessen noch notwendig, zumal wir haben jetzt extrem viele Probleme von Staatsrödern angesprochen, aber das Hauptproblem haben wir elegant umschifft, weil wir denken, dass es sowieso alle Innen- und auswendig können
Hauptproblem ist natürlich auch noch dieses Sicherheitsdilemmer, ja?
Ähm man nimmt hier, man schwächt hier die IT-Sicherheit, nicht nur durch die ähm Verpflichtung der Anbieter, sondern eben um auch wegen der Ausnutzung äh von Schwachstellen. Man lässt quasi.
Als Beispiel Schwachstellen in irgendeinem Messenger von allen sieben Milliarden Menschen in allen hundertzweiundneunzig Staaten auf der Welt offen, inklusive die eigenen.
Um dann irgendeinen Drogendealer, irgendeinen,
Querdenker, Nazi oder auch irgendeinen Mensch, der Leute über eine Grenze schmuggelt zu fangen. Und da muss man sich doch wirklich mal fragen, ist das verhältnismäßig.
Professor Matthias Becker hat am Montag in der Anhörung gesagt, also die Gefahren sind so groß, wenn der Staatssicherheitsnutz äh.
Ausnutzt, statt sie zu schließen, was das BKA übrigens auch schon mal getan hat. Die Gefahren sind so groß, es kann gar kein relevantes Anliegen eines Staates geben, diese Gefahren hinzunehmen,
ähm das IT-Grundrecht vom Bundesverfassungsgericht ist ja auch nicht nur ein Abwehrrecht
der Einzelnen, ähm dass wir einen IT-Grundrecht haben gegen das der Staat nicht einfach so eingreifen kann, sondern es ist auch ein Grundrecht, dass der Staat gewährleisten muss. Ähm der Staat muss.
Äh Vertraulichkeit und Integrität aller IT-Systeme gewährleisten.
Sehr schön formuliert oder sehr oder also sehr wichtig äh darauf hinzuweisen, weißt du, überhaupt nicht wahrgenommen wird, ne?
Genau, dieses Grundrecht ist äh nicht nur in der juristischen, auch in der politischen und auch in der fachöffentlichen äh erst recht in der breiten öffentlichen Debatte äh immer bisschen so unter ferner liefen. Aber das ist tatsächlich ein ziemlich krasses Ding,
das ist halt relativ neu, jetzt mit zwotausendachtzehn oder so wann das war, ich weiß auch nicht mehr ganz genau, Pie mal Daumen.
In den nächsten Verfassungsbeschwerden eben gegen den Staatstrojaner in der Strafprozessordnung, aber auch gegen die Verfassungsbeschwerden, gegen,
gegen diese Gesetze kommen werden, wenn sie denn beschlossen werden, äh wird dann das Bundesverfassungsgericht eben zum ersten Mal ausdefinieren,
wie es denn das jetzt genau gemeint hat äh mit dieser Gewährleistung äh von Vertraulichkeit und Integrität von IT-Systemen.
Ob es eben irgendwelche äh Fälle geben kann,
in der Aushandlung von Sicherheitslücken, wo der Staat das eventuell doch geheim halten darf.
Die meisten Juristen in der Anhörung sagen, nee, das geht nicht, ähm.
Der Verfassungsschutzpräsident Haldenwang hat sogar der hat irgendwie gesagt, ich weiß auch nicht genau, ob der sich mit den
allen technischen Details äh der Oberexperte ist. Aber der hat eine Anhörung gemeint, also irgendwelche Schwachstellen und das spielt überhaupt keine Rolle beim Staatstroher, ne.
Ich verstehe nicht, was er damit meint. Er meint, es gäbe da irgendwelche geheime Volume-Technologie, die aber natürlich nicht erklären kann, weil wenn er,
klären würde, dann würde es wieder nicht funktionieren. Ähm ich halte das äh für weit hergeholt, der wusste aber auch nicht, dass das BKA äh WhatsApp mitlesen kann, wenn sie einfach mal ganz kurz das Handy in die Hand nehmen.
Ähm.
Aber wenn sie wirklich keine äh Waschstellen ausnutzen sollten, frage ich mich erstens, was macht die Zitist den ganzen Tag? Die wurde ja dafür gegründet, äh genau sowas zu anzukaufen und zu entwickeln,
auf dem Markt zu finden und zweitens, wenn sie das wirklich nicht brauchen, wie äh der Verfassungsschutz selber behauptet, dann sollen sie ins Gesetz schreiben, dass die Sicherheitslücken nicht außen äh nicht ausnutzen und nicht ausnutzen werden und nicht ausnutzen
dürfen. Aber das schreiben sie nicht ins Gesetz und das ist ein Problem.
Ich finde, ich möchte noch kurz hier ein bisschen mich selber loben, weil meine Stellungnahme zweitausend äh siebzehn äh bei der Staatstrainer Ausweitung, die hier äh Ausweitung hatte den Titel
Risiken für die innere Sicherheit beim Einsatz von Schadsoftware in der Strafverfolgung. Finde ich nach wie vor sehr, sehr wichtigen Punkt, weil nämlich genau der
weiß genau das betrifft, was du gerade auch sagst, was Matthias Becker nochmal angesprochen hat. Wir schneiden uns hier am Ende ins eigene Fleisch. Und diese
das ein sehr schönes Beispiel dafür ist ja die ähm oder ein sehr trauriges Beispiel ist ja hier die äh Hackerangriffe oder die Schaden, die in Schäden, die weltweit entstanden sind durch
ähm zwei
beziehungsweise deine Dateien doch nicht wiederbekommen, die eine Schwachstelle.
Die NSA gehortet hat, genutzt haben, bei äh bei ihrer Ausbreitung. Und das war eine Schwachstelle, die die NSA,
mindestens fünf Jahre zu diesem Zeitpunkt hatte oder acht. Die Schwachstelle selber war noch viel älter und sie ist dann in die falschen Hände gekommen. Und was ich dazu immer sagen möchte,
Dieser Schaden, diese diese Milliardenschäden, die wir da gesehen haben, die sich da manifestiert haben, sind nur ein Bruchteil des Risikos, was die NSA für die gesamte Welt.
Jeden Tag eingegangen ist, den die ruhig geschlafen haben, mit dieser Schwachstelle in ihrem Arsenal. Und dem Explode für diese Schwachstelle, die haben jeden Tag mussten die mit damit einschlafen, zu sagen, hoffentlich äh findet niemand raus,
dass es diese Schwachstätte gibt, weil dann können wir sie weiter ausnutzen und.
Dann bricht nicht die Welt zusammen, ja? Und man kann eigentlich vom Glück sagen, dass sie irgendwann Not gefixt wurde von Microsoft.
Tatsächlichen Schäden hier waren einen Monat nachdem es die Updates gab, das heißt, was da gebissen wurde waren die Leute, die einen Monat lang, obwohl
rauf und runter in den Nachrichten kamen, hochkritische Sicherheitslücke, äh bitte unbedingt fixen. Das war nur der Teil, die die die Updates nicht hatten.
Und ähm.
Diese Risiken einzugehen, ist, denke ich, genau das, was du meinst, mit da verletzt der Staat gezielt das Grundrecht auf die Gewährleistung,
der Vertraulichkeit und Interität, Informationstechnischer Systeme und zwar aller. Und ich denke tatsächlich, dass man dass man wirklich damit Aussicht hat
zu sagen, ey, das kann nicht sein, dass der Staat Kenntnis einer Sicherheitslücke hat, die ein ein Risiko für die Wirtschaft, ein Risiko für die Bürgerinnen ist und ähm.
Dieses Risiko einfach mal eingeht, weil diese Abwägung,
zwischen, ja, ja, aber komm, ein bisschen, bisschen Heckmeck müssen wir ja auch noch machen. Äh und äh die die Bürgerinnen sollen geschützt sein, die kann eigentlich nur
immer schiefgehen.
Ja, eine der.
Laut dessen Kritik war nicht nur die Wirtschaft und die anderen Staaten, sondern auch innerhalb der USA war nach das Verteidigungsministerium, man hat zur NSA gesagt, sag mal wollt ihr uns verarschen?
Unsere Systeme laufen mit genau dieser selben Schwachstelle.
Die National Security Agency. Euer Auftrag ist es eigentlich für unsere IT-Sicherheit zu sorgen. Und ihr habt uns nicht Bescheid gesagt.
Und dann regt man sich auf wenn irgendwie staatliche Stellen gehackt werden. Das ist ein großes großes Problem, sowohl international, also ich kann nicht verstehen, wie,
man denken kann, der deutsche Staat darf das, aber alle hunderteinundneunzig anderen Staaten nicht oder auch nur das BKA wird das schon geheim halten können oder das
Landesamt für Verfassungsschutz Thüringen, wenn die NSE das nicht schafft.
Wir haben Beitrag auf Netzpolitik von zwanzig achtzehn mit dem Titel sind ein Risiko für die innere Sicherheit also die Befürworter sagen immer wir tun was für die innere Sicherheit weil wir eins, zwei, drei Bad Guys schnappen,
aber das,
dass sie die innere Sicherheit schwächen, indem sie die IT-Sicherheit aller offen halten, das will irgendwie nicht in die Gehirne. Warum auch immer.
Weil sie denken, so hat's schon immer funktioniert. Wir sind aber der Staat und wir müssen das, dürfen und außerdem.
So viel über, ja, weiß ich nicht. Ähm ein Angriff von China, damit hat doch die nichts zu tun oder so.
Oder auch nur Kriminelle. Ist ja gerade hochaktuell. Also die ist eigentlich ist die Perspektive von vielen Leuten, die sich mit dem Thema auseinandersetzen, wenn der Staat.
Von einer Sicherheitslücke erfährt, muss er alles in Bewegung setzen, dass die geschlossen wird und darf die auf keinen Fall offen halten, denn sonst kommen wir in Teufelskirche sowohl äh innerhalb einzelner Staaten als vor allem auch international.
Amen, was wird der Bundestag jetzt aus dieser Erkenntnis machen? Die werden also jetzt dieses Gesetz zur Anpassung des Verfassungsschutzrechts, da war die Anhörung am Montag. Eine Nummer,
Nothabene wie man so schön sagt. Am Montag waren wieder zwei Vertreter des äh CCC im äh in Ausschüssen des Deutschen Bundestags, nämlich einmal zum Thema ähm.
Impfpass und zum zum Thema mobile EID. Ähm sprechen wir in äh sprechen wir an anderer Stelle noch drüber.
Zu dieser äh Staatsojane Anhörung war aber keiner von von uns geladen. Bin ich ein bisschen beleidigt, hätte gerne nochmal die gleiche Stellungnahme eingereicht, äh nach Giffey, nach Giffey-Schamanier. Ähm.
Da waren übrigens auch keine Vertreter der Internetwirtschaft, also der Eco, grade Klaus oder auch der Bitcom und so, die sind ja normalerweise zu solchen Gesetzen, die sie betreffen, gerne mal da und auch äh kundige und gern gehörte Experten,
waren auch nicht da, obwohl dieses ganze riesen Fass
der Provider mitwirkungen da drin ist. Da waren eigentlich nur Juristen, aber weißt du, wer damit drin war? Herr Kurt Kraulich, das ist dieser ehemalige Bundesverwaltung
äh Gerichtsrichter
der damals im NSA Untersuchungsausschuss als Sonderermittler eingesetzt wurde, der die Selektoren teilweise angucken konnte, weil der Ausschuss das selber ja nicht angucken konnte äh und der irgendwie nicht durch übermäßige,
und Distanz zu Geheimdiensten aufgefallen ist, sondern der sogar Teile seines Berichts direkt vom BND übernommen hatte.
Und sogar den hat die SPD ernannt und der hat gesagt liebe Leute, dieses Gesetz das darf so nicht kommen.
Die SPD, die Fraktionen laden sich ja normalerweise Sachverständige ein, die so Pi mal Daumen ihrer Meinung entsprechen, aber die SPD hat da den eingeladen und der sagt,
Dieses Gesetz geht so nicht.
Und der ist jetzt echt äh unverdächtig. Äh übermäßig äh übermäßiger Grundrechtsschützer zu sein, ne.
Aber die SPD hat ja in dieser ganzen Legislatur und in diesem ganzen Themenbereich immer mal wieder rote Linien eingezogen, äh was denn mit ihnen nicht so machen sei.
Ähm.
Kann sich jeder selbst ausmalen, äh was passieren wird. Es gibt nur noch zwei Sitzungswochen des Bundestags in diesem, in dieser Legislaturperiode. Der Bundestag kommt nur noch zweimal im Juni zusammen.
Und alle Gesetze, die irgendwie angefangen wurde, wie gesagt, Discotinitätsprinzip, die noch fertig wollen sollen, die müssen jetzt im Juni beschlossen werden,
des Bundespolizeigesetzes stand eigentlich gestern, Donnerstag schon mal auf der Tagesordnung, sollte verabschiedet werden, dann gab's aber doch nochmal Streit kurz vor Schluss.
Ähm ich gehe davon aus, dass bis zum Schluss Verhandlungen passieren zwischen Union und SPD.
Und sowohl das Bundespolizeigesetz als auch das äh Geheimdienst äh Gesetz höchstwahrscheinlich äh beschlossen werden kurz vor Schluss.
Das ist jetzt keine gute Nachricht.
Ja, danke SPD.
Aber es gibt keine äh brauchbare Aussicht denkste, dass sich da noch irgendwas dran ändert.
Beim, ich glaube, es ist ein bisschen schwer reinzugucken. Sie reden auch nicht ganz so gerne sehr detailliert äh mit mir. Ähm.
Geheimdienstgesetz,
erwarte ich, dass sie versuchen, noch ein bisschen rumzuschrauben, aber ich hälte es für unwahrscheinlich, dass sie das nicht in irgendeiner Form verabschieden. Beim Bundespolizeigesetz ist mir tatsächlich nicht ganz klar, wie viele Kröten
ähm die SPD bereit ist zu schlucken und wo sie tatsächlich vielleicht doch nochmal versuchen zu ihrem Wort zu stehen,
ähm und bestimmte rote Linien äh nicht überschreiben zu lassen, eben gerade die präventive äh Trojanereinsatz.
Ähm wetten würde ich darauf nicht, äh ganz ehrlich, mit Wetten auf die SPD wird schon das Richtige tun, habe ich keine guten Erfahrung.
Wir werden sehen, vielleicht geschieht ein Wunder, aber es liegt in wie immer in der GroKo an den Silben.
Selbst mit der mächtigsten Netzpolitikerin äh des Landes als Vorsitzende dieser Partei. Es steht und fällt alles mit der SPD.
Also äh hilft es jetzt auch irgendwie, was sich bei der SPD zu melden?
Auch Abgeordnete kontaktieren äh und Kandidaten schaden tut das nie. Äh kann man schon mal machen? Inwieweit das jetzt tatsächlich noch effektiv ist? Äh also
abhalten will ich niemanden. Probiert's. Ähm vielleicht gibt's ja auch Leute
in den Parteien oder Wahlkreis Termine mit Abgeordneten, die klassische E-Mail ist halt doof und auch irgendwie das Konzept von Ruf deinen Abgeordneten an, also ich frage mich wie oft, ich weiß nicht wie oft ich das schon gehört habe und ich weiß nicht, wie viele Leute das jemals überhaupt schon mal gemacht haben.
Schaden tut das nicht. Kann man gerne machen, aber eigentlich ist die Abwägung 'ne andere. Das Gesetz ist das Geheimdienst Gesetz das liegt auch schon seit
Oktober auf Eis. Das wurde damals schon von der Bundesregierung äh zwischen den SPD-Ministerien
ähm geeinigt. Das lag dann aber erstmal fünf Monate flach, weil die Sozen eigentlich im Gegenzug dazu auch noch ein Unternehmensstrafrecht wollten. Also ein anderer großer Deal, was übrigens auch nicht kam,
ähm aber die Abwägung.
Quellen TKÖ jetzt in der Plusform kommt oder nicht oder ob das jetzt alle neunzehn oder nur,
drei Geheimdienste kriegen da eigentlich könnte man versuchen daran noch etwas zu drehen genau jetzt nach der Sachverständigenanhörung am Montag laufen ja auch noch die finalen
stimmung im Innenausschuss zwischen der großen Koalition, inwieweit die Paar Abgeordneten der SPD-Fraktion im Innenausschuss
davon zu überzeugen sind, also ich will niemand abhalten, go for it. Auf mich hören sie nicht mehr.
Oh Mann, Andre, ich äh jetzt weiß ich wieder, warum ich äh.
Mir nicht Podcast, ja?
Oh Mann.
Lass mal ein Bier trinken muss.
Schnaps äh bevor die Spätis hier zumachen und ich keine kein äh keinen Flachmann mehr für die für die Jeans Jeansweste äh bekomme.
Danke ich dir, dass du diese Themen trotzdem ähm weiter so genau beackerst. Es gibt auch glaube ich tatsächlich wenige, die das auf dem
Niveau tun wie du und deswegen ist es ja so wichtig unsere Freundinnen und Freunde bei Netzpolitik org zu unterstützen, genauso wie es auch wichtig ist ähm.
Uns bei Lokbuch Netzpolitik zu unterstützen.
Und ich wünsche uns dann, würde ich sagen, einfach eine schöne, einen schönen Sommer, weil wenigstens eins ist sicher, wenigstens,
ist äh ist dieser äh äh diese Dedosangriff mit äh Grundrechtsverletzenden und hochkritischen äh auf die letzte Sekunde durchgepeitschten Gesetzesvorhaben bald vorbei. Dann haben wir allerdings einen Wahlkampf und das wird bestimmt auch richtig schön.
Genau, hier, es hört ja nicht vollständig auf, erstens gibt's noch andere Ebenen, wie äh Länder und auch die EU-Ebene und zweitens genau Wahlkampf, Koalitionsverhandlungen.
Immer weiter.
Bin gespannt, ob die Grünen aus ihrem Parteiprogramm den Staatsfreund noch streichen. Die haben ja jahrelang immer gesagt, Staatstrojaner geht nie unter keinen Umständen, auf gar keinen Fall, weil aus all den richtigen Argumenten. Aber im Entwurf für ihr Wahlprogramm steht drin, ja, also Quellenticker Ü,
die Kröte müssen wir halt schlucken. Bin gespannt, ob das noch mal rauskommt.
Ich habe gedacht, wir hätten jetzt ein erklärtes äh erklärtes Feindbild hier und äh und jetzt kommen die Grünen auch noch mit dazu.
Dann reden wir jetzt nicht von Hessen und den NSU-Akten, diese diese Woche nicht freigegeben haben.
Die Grünen haben sich auch bei der bei der Urheberrechtsreform enthalten, da hätten sie hätte sie doch auch nichts gekostet, dagegen zu stimmen, äh.
Man merkt die, die sehen, die riechen die Möglichkeit auf Regierungsbeteiligung, ne. Da werden sie sofort da werden sie sofort äh handzahm. Schade eigentlich.
Ulberich ist sowieso nochmal ein eigenes Thema, aber du hast ja gerade einen eigenen Podcast dazu gemacht. Eigentlich wolltest du mit mir eine Viertelstunde übern Trojaner reden, aber ist jetzt doch ein bisschen länger geworden.
So ist das. Äh Andre, ich danke dir. Ich wünsche dir ein schönes Wochenende. Und ich mache mich an die zeitnahe Veröffentlichung dieser Episode.
Alles klar, danke bei dir.
Hoffen wir jetzt, ich hab's gerade auch zu Julia schon gesagt, ich weiß gar nicht, ob ich mich, ob ich sagen soll, ich ich freue mich, dich bald wieder im Podcast zu haben.
He.
Ciao Andre.
Ciao, ciao.